One of the things I've said about,
uh,
one of the more bizarre things about today's political climate is that people
selectively agree with science.
It's like when it comes to client climate change,
like everybody is like pro science,
like science all the way.
Look at the studies.
Yeah.
Even when they don't even understand the studies,
there's a famous,
and you know,
you get in trouble when you bring up Tucker Carlson because people go,
oh,
you're Tucker Carlson Fan.
I'm just as a human being,
I'm not going to made,
he made some very good points with Bill Nye.
He had bill Nye on,
they were talking about science and he said,
okay,
if human beings are responsible for climate change,
what percentage?
What are the numbers like?
And Bill Nye really isn't a scientist.
He's a science.
Um,
you know,
what would your personality,
those immediate personality,
he's a guy who's a,
you know,
he's,
um,
a promoter of science,
but not really necessarily scientist.
So He's,
he doesn't,
he doesn't have long term study and research to climate change.
He's just sort of on there in a slightly arrogant way saying things that I agree
with.
Like what I agree with is that human beings are responsible,
at least in part with climate change.
This is where all the research points to.
Yeah.
But when Tucker Carlson was pressing him on it,
he really didn't have any answers for it.
So it's one of those things where like people on the left will blindly support
science in one way.
Is that you or me?
Dang it.
If it's me,
I'm gonna be very upset with myself because I don't think it's me.
Um,
but then when it comes to gender,
you watch his show.
He's got this wacky show on Netflix.
Yeah.
Where there they're singing songs about gender can be fluid and gender could be
this and this is more than two.
Yeah.
There's more than two genders,
which she didn't use to say.
Yeah.
If you go back to one of us,
I did see that there was an older episode where they clearly say that gender is
a binary.
Yeah.
This was like way back before all this nuttiness step.
So it's influencing people who are in the know,
like the people are deciding instead of supporting science and supporting the
research on actual human beings as a biological organism.
Instead we're going with this bizarre politically correct climate which inclines
people to this weird delusional thinking.
And as an outsider,
that's what's interesting to me to watch all this scrambling,
looking at this weirdness.
You know,
it's hypocritical.
It definitely is.
And it's,
it's interesting to see,
I mean say the march for Science,
I attended that not this past year but the year before.
So people are there.
They're super excited about science,
Pro Science,
I think science great.
All this money should go to science and you ask them,
okay,
so you're,
so you're down for climate change being real.
But what about science?
Now by the left,
and I asked so many people this while I was there because I was reporting on it
for playboy.com and um,
it's amazing.
People get very uncomfortable.
They don't want to,
they don't want to say anything about,
I would consider myself to be a liberal,
but definitely liberals don't want to think about themselves being science
deniers.
And when you look at how people talk about gender now and biological sex
differences in the brain,
even biology more generally,
people get very defensive.
They get angry almost,
and they,
if they find it threatening for some reason,
which I don't understand,
and that's a big part of my work is to say,
I think we can acknowledge that these facts exist and that biological sciences
legitimate.
That doesn't mean that sexism is okay.
We're not saying that women are inferior or anything like that.
Exactly.
That's the big point about all this,
right,
is that we're not saying that anyone's inferior or just not the same thing.
This is what the big problem is.
The tried to say,
I mean,
I certainly think we should all have equal rights,
but we're not equal in terms of what we are.
We're a different,
we're in,
it's not that we're not equal,
like one's better.
It's just like saying a wolf is not equal to a cheetah.
They're fucking different things.
Yeah.
And males and females are different things.
And this is,
this is clear when you study us as an organism,
you know,
I had a really bizarre conversation once with a guy who's a professor or a
former professor and he was trying to deny that there that there's a difference
between men and women.
It's crazy.
And one of the things I said,
I said,
okay,
you get a dog.
Uh,
do you ask,
is this a boy dog or a girl dog?
And then he got like real weird.
But this is really no answer to that.
Like it's,
it's a fucking boy dog.
You want a boy dog,
right?
Is it a non-binary doll?
Like what is your dog?
All right.
It might change its mind tomorrow as your dog gender fluid.
Yeah.
Like what does gender fluid,
well,
it's this idea that you can be one gender one day and another gender the other
day or it might cycle through the day or Dawson.
Your mix of both.
That seems like if it was anything else,
you would have to be fucking crazy.
Right?
It was anything else?
Yeah.
Like if you decided,
well today I'm African.
Yeah.
Tomorrow I'm Chinese,
you know,
today,
uh,
I'm tall tomorrow,
I'm short today,
I'm a Pixie tomorrow I'm a wood Elf
like,
but I think everybody is,
we don't have to call it something like gender fluid.
Everyone is a mix of male and female.
Right?
Like you will have people that are maybe more typically masculine or more
typically feminine,
but even still there,
there's no,
I don't think there are many people that are 100% not one way or the other not,
well,
what does that even mean?
I mean,
people are clearly more masculine than other people,
but does that mean that the people like,
you know,
let's pick a person,
Bill Nye.
Does that mean he's not
ma'am,
he's clearly a man.
Exactly.
Yeah.
He's clearly a man.
He's not a Lebron James,
but he's a man.
Yeah.
You know,
there's,
there's obviously a spectrum.
Yeah.
I almost feel like that way of thinking is more old fashion because this is all
about being progressive and open minded.
But I think if someone is a man but is maybe more female typical to say that
this person has a different category of gender or that they're,
I don't know,
not mail.
To me that's more stereotypical.
You know what I mean?
I think it's,
it's not progressive to say if you are a mix of both,
you must be something different.
This is really a mix of both,
right?
You just have a different hormonal profile are different.
It's different
body types,
different,
I mean people vary so much that,
I mean I think having some sort of categories to say,
oh,
this is a male and this is a female.
It seems like it's pretty beneficial.
I mean although we vary so widely inside those categories to pretend that those
categories don't exist to seem so weird.
We would never do that with any other organism and it's a lot of work too.
You see these companies going in there trying to be more and with the times I
guess in there.
Everything is gender neutral now and I'm thinking all of that money and time is
being wasted when I don't think that does anything for,
for women or sexism.
If you changed instead of addressing someone by ladies and gentlemen,
you say people is that really gonna stop sexism just makes people mad because
then they have to change the way they talk.
I put of a story on Twitter the other day about people that are raising their
kids with they and them.
I saw that.
Yeah,
calling them they beat instead of babies.
Fun Times.
The fuck is that like I just,
I think it's coming from,
for some parents it's coming from a good place.
Like they obviously want the best for their kids and they don't want to limit
the kid in terms of what they might be interested in.
And I think because the media is telling them,
if you let girls play with dolls,
that's terrible and they're going to end up,
you know,
not having any sort of prospects when they grow up in terms of their jobs or,
I don't know,
it's such a terrible thing to be female.
Typical nowadays.
But I mean,
like you mentioned,
it's biology that's going to dictate what your kids play with.
And then in other cases,
I think it's parents that want to be special.
Well,
it's also weird because if your son is trans,
it's totally fine for him to be female.
Typical.
Yeah.
It's celebrated.
Like if you have a trans son and he likes wearing lipstick and short skirts and
prancing around,
then he's fabulous.
Like there was a boy in New York and there was this whole thing about he's the
youngest ever drag queen and everybody's going crazy.
And people were angry about it.
You know,
some people were angry and saying he's being exploited by his parents,
and some people thought it was wonderful that this kid was so expressive when
he's so young.
And then other people said,
I had a good point.
They said,
well,
it's very sexualized.
Like how is this any different than someone who's in a beauty pageant,
like a Jon Benet Ramsey type situation?
Well,
I think it was,
if it was a little girl,
people would be up in arms and sexist and that it's the patriarchy.
But that little boy,
so I don't know that he's trans.
I believe that he just likes to like a man who is a drag queen is just a man.
It's usually gay men who likes to play chess.
You know,
like an extreme form of femininity.
I love drag Queens,
but I think that little boy is likely going to grow up to be a gay boy.
If you have a little boy who says he's a girl and you see a lot of these trans
girls,
if they were left alone and they didn't transition,
they would like the research shows.
They would grow up to be gay men is that
I'm 100% for freedom,
right?
So I'm 100% for you being able to
do whatever you want to do.
The real question becomes when people are Trans and young,
it's uh,
how much,
how much of this is going to pass and how much of this are you going to stop
from ever passing because you're going to inject your body fold with hormones.
Like,
are you giving yourself the opportunity just to decide to become a gay man
versus become a woman?
And would you be happier either or?
It's very,
very tricky.
You can't even have that conversation now,
right?
You can't transphobic,
right.
What it is is homophobic though that you can consider that some of these kids
just might be gay children.
But then the,
the gender fluid one,
I was reading this article about this guy who varies by the day and it like in
the day,
like he'll have periods of stress,
we'll switch over to a woman.
There was actually a radio lab podcast where they interviewed a person that has
the same issue and um,
the person was clearly abnormal in the way they communicated and the way they
thought.
It wasn't like you were dealing with some guy that you would trust with your
taxes.
You know what I mean?
It was like the dude was wacky and then now he's a check and now he's back to
being a guy again.
And he actually transitioned in mid conversation like physically.
Now.
I don't know.
I didn't see it because you're just listening,
but he's like,
well,
now I'm Peter again.
Now I'm wondering,
you know like what the fuck?
Hi Lindy.
Well,
it's,
I don't know how much of that is indulgent.
I mean,
I don't want,
I don't want to say I know how you feel,
but I do want to say,
hey,
are you fucking crazy?
Is this,
are we just,
we just indulging crazy people.
I do believe there are people that are trans.
I absolutely believe that there that there are women that really are wired the
wrong way and they should be men and there's men that are wired the wrong.
It only makes sense.
Yeah,
but I do also think there's people that are crazy.
There's people that have legit mental illness,
they're delusional and they're also very susceptible to influence and very
susceptible to,
you know,
someone persuading them that they are one thing or another thing.
Look,
it's those like heaven's gate cult people who cut their balls off and wore the
Nike's and decided to kill themselves when the comment was near.
Remember that,
yeah,
that's not normal,
right?
It's not normal for someone to be able to talk you into cutting your balls off
or putting on the purple sneakers or killing yourself when the comments close
because there's a spaceship waiting.
It's going to take you to Xenu or wherever the fuck you're going.
Right?
That's not normal either.
So we know that people are subject to very irrational behavior under the
influence of other people's suggestions or other people's,
you know,
persuasion.
And this is a thing today where you have to wonder like how many of these people
are legitimately trans?
How many of these people are legitimately dealing with like a real mental issue
that's causing them to shift from male to female and back again?
And why is it that we can't ask these questions cause why is it that even this
question right now,
I could be accused of being transphobic for asking how many of these people are
ill?
Yeah,
well both of us are going to be accused of transphobia after this.
Yeah.
I mean I would agree with that.
I do think that gender dysphoria is a legitimate phenomenon and I do have a lot
of empathy for people who are suffering.
And I think for adults they should be allowed to transition if that's what they
decide to do,
if that's something that will help them feel better.
My issues with the kids,
it's,
I don't think it's appropriate for children to be transitioning.
And I can talk a bit more about why,
but I think in terms of the pathology aspect,
I think for,
because gender is so trendy right now and in the past you might have seen this
kind of pathology manifests in a different way.
But now because everyone is saying genders,
the way to express,
you know,
I think people also see a fever problem in your life.
They think it's gender related.
So say with some of the personality disorder and people like a lot of attention,
they like to,
um,
it's always about them and their identity and their identity shifts a lot.
So this could very well be what it is and now they're being basically rewarded
for that.
Yeah,
that's the issue,
right?
That you're dealing with incredibly indulgent people which do exist and they
then they find this pathway to massive amounts of attention.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean this is,
I,
I had to construct a bit to mock Caitlyn Jenner,
but it was a very complicated bit like I had to figure out how to do this.
Yeah.
I was like,
obviously this is nonsense and foolish,
but I don't want to appear cruel.
So what is a way to do this?
So my way was to mock myself mercilessly and which is a kind of true,
like I really do have three daughters and I really do get brutalized in my
house.
Like I really do think they chip away at my man.
No,
it's kind of a joke,
but I mean it really is.
It's all girly in my house.
My fucking house is so girly,
everyone's girly.
They're always talking about girly shit.
It's kind of hilarious.
Yeah.
But the joke was that if my manhood was a mountain of marbles,
every day they take two marbles,
they just take one.
Like you don't even need these.
These are,
what do you care,
cod.
And then that I'm not going to go out like Bruce Jenner and that one,
that one day that they,
so I had to concoct this whole thing that they were demons,
which is how they conjured up all that money.
Like how else would they have hundreds of millions of dollars through no
discernible reason.
Yeah.
There's no,
there's no way you could like explain to someone how they made so much money if
they didn't understand our culture.
Yeah,
totally irrational.
Right.
So the idea was that that they did this,
but why did it was I wanted to sort of mock this thing that was happening where
you got to mail Kardashians.
That's what he,
I mean there's,
and who doesn't believe in gay marriage?
Who Decides?
He's a woman,
which I firmly believe he's trans.
I'm not,
not denying that at all,
but our obsession with it and rewarding him with ungodly amounts of attention.
This mother fucker won the gold medal.
Okay.
In the decathlon,
was it the calf on was right?
Yeah.
I mean it was on the cover of Wheaties.
I mean,
he was a fucking us superstar athlete and then no attention after that,
he was the whipping boy of the Kardashians on their TV show.
They mocked him.
It's like,
here's this one person with fucking town,
your whole house.
They mock rob a bit fat,
but then they go right to that.
He becomes a woman and now he is the toast of the town.
He wins woman of the fucking year.
He's a woman for six months and he wins woman of the year.
He Wins Espn athlete of the year.
He has been an athlete and fucking decades since Nixon was president.
Right.
Or Carter,
who was it?
Either way,
this is madness.
This is,
we're,
we're not treating this in a balanced way where we are rewarding people that
instead of like,
because people are so,
they're,
they're so ready to proclaim the progressiveness and so excited about it that
they,
instead of like,
instead of treating them like as an equal,
they,
they go completely the other way.
So they're definitely not prejudiced.
They're definitely not discriminating against them,
but they're absolutely inflating what this person is and they're making it a big
giant deal that they're trans.
Like,
it's great to support people.
I would like to live in a world where there's no racism at all.
So you could mock everyone equally.
Yeah.
Like this is my big problem with real racism.
There's a lot of dummies in every race,
but you gotta be real careful picking on some dummies.
Like specially if you're a white male,
straight,
white male oppressor.
You guys are the devil nowadays.
Especially if you look like me.
I mean,
I looked like the devil.
So this is a,
this is a real problem with like looking at things in a balanced perspective
cause you're not allowed to,
you're not allowed to.
Like even what you said earlier,
you said gender dysphoria,
you know that's considered transphobic.
Yeah.
You can't even say that anymore even though that is a legitimate medical
condition.
Yeah,
it can because some people see it as you pathologizing being the way someone
feels,
I guess,
but in my mind I don't think the issue is pathology.
The pathology,
I think it's fine to acknowledge there are certain things like any,
any medical condition that causes you distress and impairment.
That's,
that's the definition of a psychiatric diagnosis,
so you should be able to recognize that it's not a bad thing.
I think the bad thing is the stigma that comes along with having a mental
disorder.
So that's what should be fought.
It's the stigma aspect,
not calling something a mental disorder.
If someone's,
if someone's really suffering,
that's not a good thing.
No,
no.
It's not a good thing.
And the denial of these conditions and the denial of the science behind these
conditions.
This is the issue with progressive people today,
is that there's certain things with a embrace science and certain things where
they deny it and in gender,
gender in particular seems to be so hotly contested,
and I don't know when this happened,
it seems to have happened right in front of our face.
Like it,
it just came out of the ground like,
like a plant that was growing in the cracks that you try to stomp it out and it
won't go away.
I'm wondering,
I'm wondering where they're like,
I didn't see this.